coming off the skyscraper highs of
episode 3 I think some people may find
episode 4 underwhelming in comparison
but it's still a great overall package
it may be slower Parts however that's
necessary in creating a realistic Pace
the scenes in between this time all felt
like they had a purpose and I wouldn't
classify any of this as filler like I've
seen people say a lot of this material
relates to Ellie trying to chip away at
Joel's Viewpoint of Ellie being cargo
hearing him say that was very crushing
and it seems like Ellie wants a better
relationship because she first asked
Joel if she was family to him she's been
trying really hard to bond with him and
this resistance he gives off makes their
dialogue scenes really good it offers a
point of conflict within their
relationship of whether or not Joel
opened up more in each moment and if
Ellie will become Sarah and Joel's eyes
in each episode so far there has been a
progression like in the last episode
Joel and Ellie were barely on speaking
terms and now that they are Ellie is
trying to further push that line to Joel
liking her come company even for this
episode the relationship starting point
is vastly different from where it ends
that's why I think some of these scenes
like the car ride dialogue and the
campsite setting were so important
because it sets up a point in their
relationship that they then progress
from later on and again these are really
entertaining moments like with Ellie
reading jokes to Joel and trying to make
him laugh and her discovering a porn
magazine it's a very human and awkward
moment and Ellie using these Avenues is
a clever way to bond with Joel why are
all these Pages stuck together uh her
attempts at humor are endearing and is a
direct contrast to the lifeless nature
of the world and even Joel she's
essentially slowly reinvigorating him
and seeing this process no matter how
slow it may be will always be great to
watch like I love this moment where she
delivers her first joke and Pedro Pascal
has an extremely subtle expression as to
him kind of liking it but suppressing it
you can see his tense face partially
ease up and I think this was a good
first step visually for Joel to relax a
bit this recurring beat for their
characters I think acts as a good
checkpoint for us to directly compare
their growth throughout the episode
because we go from Joel tolerating her
jokes to finally giving in and
delivering off a warm laugh so the plot
in this episode may not pop off but I
still love the dialogue and the type of
relationship that Joel and Ellie have in
the show I also find it kind of weird
how people are saying this episode isn't
very good but yet this feature is the
most of Joel and Ellie together and I
thought that's what people wanted so
much because from a game to show
adaption for this episode it's almost
one to one besides the inclusion of
Kathleen I think her character felt a
bit off because how is the seemingly
non-powerful character in charge of this
revolutionary group when she's
surrounded by these other characters who
look visually stronger her brief scenes
when talking to everyone didn't exude a
lot of confidence and she didn't give
off strong leader Vibes also her
introductory scene didn't land as hard
as I felt like it was intended because
of how much missing context there was
surrounding these two characters the
writing here tells you enough to
understand what's going on but I don't
think we share a similar emotional
connection to what was going on then
when she comes back in Midway through
her speech to execute the doctor and
then goes back outside again felt weird
pacing wise to me this wasn't the most
compelling introduction for a new
villain character and I think it could
have had a slightly better execution
that and the nature of her character I
feel like would have had a hard time
convincing all these people with her
lies and manipulation it makes me want
this guy who actually is the voice actor
for Tommy in the game to be the villain
his design is a lot more unique and
badass and doesn't resemble a Karen who
probably used to be a soccer mom this
overall group though I think is an
interesting exploration as if a people
run government is better than the one
prior it illustrates how selfishly human
driven this group is through Kathleen's
character it is mostly her using people
to accomplish her own goals it creates a
much more personally driven and fleshed
out threat that surrounds Joel and Ellie
in the setting because in the game these
are basically unnamed people who wanted
loot which we can go from this and talk
about the Ambush because this was a
horrific scene this was a perfect
Recreation from the game and every
detail was replicated with immense
Precision starting out I love the quick
reactions that Bella Ramsey gives off
where she's shocked and dismayed about
how Joel is about to run over this guy
asking for help then them crashing into
the laundromat was a crazy stunt and it
looked very realistic like there was
obviously no way for them to cheat that
since they literally crashed the car
into this building and you can see the
Sun actors in the car taking on that
crash easy 10 out of 10 stunts the
shootout following this was equally good
and the aspect about the scene in
particular that I loved was the sound
design and music the shots were so loud
you could hear the bass of each shot the
bullets penetrating every single
distinct surface making each shot sound
unique and realistic the Raiders mocking
and yelling at our characters like the
NPCs from the game and the music slowly
building the entire time making the
eventual confrontation of violence that
much better
okay
then the music eases off as Joel kills
one of the Raiders in a release of
tension just a perfect one minute of
Television that doesn't stop here
because we now transition into a more
suspenseful moment as the writer enters
the building seeing this moment from the
perspective of Ellie enhances this
because it's more tense not knowing who
has the advantage or who is about to die
in the room behind her even when Joel
shoots the Intruder we still shortly
question the fact if Joel was the one
who shot or got shot then the scene
keeps going when they think everything
is fine to then having another Raider
surprise us from the back door from a
writing perspective this entire scene is
so genius because it breaks up the
action into three varied parts we have
the initial explosion of action that is
the car crash in the shootouts the more
suspense driven moment of hiding from
the Raider in the twist of thinking
we're in the clear to then throwing
another dire obstacle at our protagonist
it creates a good and balanced flow
throughout the the action scene then the
last moment allows Ellie to finally save
Joel and she shoots a human being which
on its own is another important ordeal
to explore this is a masterful scene
from writing to execution and the
screams and pleading coming from the
poor guy is insanely haunting like
honestly one of the best performances
from an extra that I've seen in a while
him crying out for his mom really
blurred the lines as if Joel and Ellie
were the bad guys in the scenario
because despite them defending
themselves they are still executing this
kid who is no longer a threat but sadly
it's necessary for them since he can
offer the enemy intel having the death
of this guy play out through the
perspective of Ellie is a double
positive we can see the rich performance
as she deals with the traumatic
experience and by not directly focusing
on the death visually it doesn't make
the violence feel gratuitous the kind of
impact this has on Ellie is very nuanced
because emotionally it's affecting her
but her practicality overrides that
because she knows that they are still in
danger it just needs to function like an
adult this kind of perseverance makes me
love Ellie because she's a strong
character despite being a child she's
not immediately becoming incapacitated
to emotions in her Instinct of survival
is still operating at full capacity and
overall great acting moment from Bella
Ramsay this whole plot Point allows Joel
to finally make an attempt to act like a
father Ellie has done an unthinkable
task of shooting someone as a kid and
Joel can't help but feel guilty for
having put her in that situation
regardless of whether or not it was
forced upon them this to me is what I
would identify as the turning point for
their relationship together through this
traumatic experience they are deeply and
inherently entangled now and it is
inscapable to not deal with the immense
emotional baggage of executing someone
Joel was trying his hardest to keep his
relationship with Ellie at a surface
level but he would be doing a disservice
to himself as a father if you didn't try
to console Ellie and since this trade
has been unlocked within Joel We now see
him given into Ellie's humor and before
he breaks in a foot of laughter at the
end he makes his own joke towards Ellie
here
this natural progression between Joel
and Ellie is painstakingly detailed and
every interaction that they have feels
important that's why I would never
classify their earlier scenes together
as filler because it's necessary build
up to make this eventual turn even more
powerful because the second Joel lets
loose and finally laughs is probably
going to be one of my favorite moments
in the show such a wholesome moment with
excellent long-awaited payoff then for
the last aspect I loved was the detail
of Joel turning over in his sleep
towards bad year was the one exposed
which explains why Henry was able to
sneak up on them a great moment that
perfectly explains itself if he paid
attention for this episode I have seen a
lot of people say that it should have
been combined with the next one because
it feels incomplete but I think John
Ellie's personal Journey offers a good
end point for episode 4. plot wise it
does end on a cliffhanger but we don't
know how long the next episode will be
for all we know episode 5 could be over
an hour long and if they combine these
two episodes it could have been two
hours long which would be getting
ridiculous so a slightly under 50 minute
episode I think is perfectly acceptable
and it does enough within its time to be
satisfying it may not go as hard as the
first three episodes but that's really
tough competition and of itself from how
amazing those ones were you can't really
have 10 out of 10 episodes constantly
and having an eight every now and then
is natural especially since this episode
gives our characters a bit of a breather
and a big chance to develop thank you
for watching and by the way the next
episode airs on Friday since HBO doesn't
want to air episode 5 against the Super
Bowl so imagine being cowards HBO
foreign